the university of austin new university
starting by our friend barry weissen and
crew
um
to combat what the hell is going on in
our used universities well i i just love
that people are building something and
uh trying to do it better you know one
of the real issues in american life is
we're all just starting to get very very
negative about things like institutions
and be like oh
you know the media oh you know like
schools uh you name it um and then
someone
like barry and a lot of other people
just want to actually put their money
where their mouth is and say hey we
think we can do a better job we think
there's a need we can fill it uh you
know that's what i'm doing with a
forward party that's what i think that
our this movement's been about in large
part it's like we can do better it's
like build a better mousetrap you know
it's like like the the the moment you
stop complaining and start doing
something about it then in my mind i've
always felt much more positive and
upbeat and healthier because when you
complain
um there's like a kind of negative
sentiment that creeps up because you're
like oh that sucks this sucks
and then at some point you have to be
like well if it really does suck
maybe i can offer the world a better
alternative and oh by the way if i'm
right
maybe there's an immense opportunity
there maybe there's a ton of value
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to the podcast
we're going to talk about what's going
on in dc they passed a bill they passed
a big bill
the 1.2 trillion dollar infrastructure
bill what's in it what's next we're also
going to talk about the automation of
home buying via zillow that kind of blew
up in everyone's face so that that
that's very on theme for us in terms of
uh you know trends mega trends and
technology in the economy also going to
talk about a new university austin
university i gotta say they picked a
pretty catchy place in the name because
it seems like austin is blowing up
today on the podcast but first
they did it they passed the
infrastructure bill yay
congratulations america i promised
something approximately
two weeks too late for a certain
gubernatorial candidate in virginia
maybe i should
i shouldn't laugh but uh it's
i have to say that
this was
something of a comedy of errors where
that they would just go back and forth
on a bill that was approved three months
ago by the senate with 19 republican
senators it's popular something like 70
percent of americans are for
infrastructure because it's common sense
we can see our country is crumbling
around us there are bridges that have
been shut down for months because
they're unsafe
[Laughter]
you look around here like if any thing
could win nearly universal claim its
infrastructure and uh they managed to
sit on it for months and months but it
finally got passed
we did it
i think
i was trying to take a step back in
these big picture stuff andrew it's like
yeah i'd say it's america spending a
trillion dollars
on fixing its infrastructure
now theoretically
there's gonna be a ton of government
waste in there or it's probably in
practice but realistically that's a good
thing it should be jobs it should be
stuff that needs to be fixed and frankly
in my opinion i know your thoughts on
this
if you're going to overspend on
something i feel like infrastructure is
a good one to overspend on
it it's really not possible for us to
overspend on infrastructure at least i
mean i guess it's conceivable but i saw
one estimate by the engineers of america
um who gave us something like a c minus
an infrastructure and estimated that our
infrastructure
deficit is something like four trillion
so actually we're not enough at one
trillion yeah so
it's a huge win uh
i mean we have been under investigate
under investing in our infrastructure
for
decades essentially uh and so this 1.2
trillion and not all this 1.2 trillion
is real because of the magic of
government accounting so 550 billion of
it is new
and you should also know that it's not
like this money is going to get spent
immediately it's going to take months
even years in many cases for
the investment to reach the economy
um but i i don't think anyone could look
at this and say that somehow uh the us
is going overboard uh this is a much
needed
long overdue investment right so you've
got i have a feeling most people listen
to this they're probably well informed
but don't watch cable news or maybe have
dug into this so i'll break it down for
you quickly
100 billion on roads and bridges 65
billion on railroads which by the way
if amtrak gets an upgrade even wi-fi
that's a pretty good win at least for
the east coast the new moynihan train
station
in new york in new york wonderful yeah
it's like you you stepped into a world
of possibility i agreed um so if there's
more like that around the country
because of this home run home run uh
they need a better food court which is
coming um right now i think it's just
like a starbucks and a
small fancy bakery uh
65 billion for the power grid which
theoretically is great if spent well um
hopefully on some clean energy but also
just climate change infrastructure in
there which is part of it too you've got
broadband particularly in rural areas
you've got 50 billion on water
infrastructure which is
i mean flint is one example of
probably hundreds frankly um the united
states america we're supposed to have
good water guys uh 47 billion on cyber
security and climate change uh in the
way it's related to that tough it was
confusing how they tied those together
um maybe it's like i don't know they're
breaking things out i guess uh public
transit almost 40 billion dollars
25 billion for airports 21 billion for
the environment which is i guess
separate than the cyber security
infrastructure
carve out 17 billion for ports which is
an issue particularly on the west coast
uh an 11 billion for safety 8 billion
for
more water infrastructure on the west
and particularly for the drought uh
ridden states 7.5 billion for electric
vehicle charging stations was awesome
and 7.5 billion for lecture school buses
yeah so you hear that list and you're
like i like these things
most americans yeah or we're bad at
these things
[Laughter]
yes
um so there there is one
um well there are probably several but
there was one big component that joe ran
on that is not included in this bill
and that is a move towards much lower
emissions there's certainly some
sustainability in there
but one of the criticisms about this
bill is that a lot of the money could
just get spent on for example
making new roads
and so there could be
a lot of uh emissions and energy
involved and just like building things
that have
environmental impact
so that's one criticism you know i i
wish that there was inclusion of
something like a carbon tax which i'm a
huge fan of um so that this is
a win massive
step in the right direction uh but i
will say that to the extent that there
was like a vision for infrastructure as
like a huge shift towards sustainability
like this is not that right um but it
has a bunch of things in it that are
positive in that direction uh in terms
of electric vehicle support uh and some
other steps i have lots of questions i
think maybe people do too um
for andrew um so the first one is
you talked about about when you're
writing a present about government's
core competencies you know uh when you
talk about ubi you're like well this is
a core giving large number of checks uh
large enough people probably reliably
every month is a core competency
is infrastructure a core competency of
government it's probably not core but it
is something i think government has to
do what do you think there so so here's
the process uh it's not that when you
cut checks for these billions of dollars
really what the government is doing is
it's cutting checks yeah and so the the
procurement processes yeah so the checks
are going in large part to
uh state and local governments that will
then say hey
we've got this money from the feds
and then how are we going to deploy it
so
they'll be able to make use of that
money and then that money in real life
gets uh spent on
a host of contractors who have great
relationships with the city and state
governments being like hey when it's
bridge repair money highway building
time or broadband billing time like you
know it's going to be us
um so when you ask about the
you know the efficiency of the resources
i think most of us know that a lot of
these construction projects have ghastly
overruns
yes
you know they cost two times or three
times as much they they take three times
as long um so there's a lot of that
that's gonna go on and again this money
is gonna get spent over a multi-year
period easily but you know like the
first real impacts are going to be from
businesses that are hiring up to be like
ooh this money's coming this money's
coming we're going to get a big contract
so we're going to need to try and help
fulfill it and that stuff will have
immediate dividends
but
we can look forward to really money
getting pumped into
uh various projects uh so when you ask
like is this a core company of the
federal government they're cutting
checks um and so you ask really like how
good is the state and local government
at actually putting shovels in the
ground and doing these things and that's
like the us in in my view has been below
average in terms of efficiency
like so there are some things where
international comparables it was like
you know we spend five to ten times more
for similar projects yes as other
countries
uh so is this a core competency of the
federal government they're cutting
checks which again is their competency
and then you hope for a higher level of
accountability and efficiency at the
local level
so i've met with
a number of directly with a number of
republican and democratic governors um
and
doing some various advising and such uh
i just want to intercede one of my ideas
on the presidential campaign that some
people loved and some people didn't like
but like i proposed creating
uh like a legion of builders and
destroyers which were essentially like
this kind of bulked-up
federal program yeah army corps of
engineers type who just come in freaking
just demolish things and
always build them with the thought being
that look if the federal government's
going to do these things it should have
some
direct resources to deploy and not just
funnel money towards
towards certain projects and and one of
the things that that you know i saw was
when you had urban cores that become
derelict it's like a real problem and
most of the time those cities don't have
the resources to do anything about it
and so if you just had
a national resource where it's like hey
this freaking town
probably could use some
destroying
[Laughter]
because that if you and if you drive
this country you know what i'm talking
about where you see all these places
where you're like what the hell happened
here and then no one has the money to
properly demolish and treat it and
a lot of these buildings become
environmental
uh
pollutants
they become havens for crime they become
blight and reduce property values so
there there's a ton of that if you drive
the country and uh you know i want to do
something about that some of this money
will probably find its way in in that
direction
but i did propose actually having a
national
a national force for it
[Music]
all right we're going to talk about
modernity
environmentalism
and tushy
oh it's true a lot of other countries
have figured out that it's easier
on everyone if you use some water
instead of toilet paper and that's what
tushy does it's a modern bidet it just
gets affixed to your toilet i know i
know it's a little bit funny but it's
also a lot awesome it's one reason why
i'm very happy to talk tushy on the pod
tushy is practical it can reduce your
toilet paper use by 80 it saves you
money over time it's good for the planet
if this sounds good to you
start washing with tushy go to
hellotushy.com yang to get 10 off plus
free shipping again that's hello
tushie.com for 10 off and after you buy
and install it you can show it off you
can tag it on hellotushi on instagram
and then they will be very happy with
you but it's good for you good for the
planet good for everyone
[Music]
i was gonna say i met with a number of
republican and democratic governors
and here's how this process works when a
bill like this is passed you're
basically giving states particularly
governors
car not carte blanche there are
restrictions but you basically are
you're putting the power
of the purse here with this money in
their hands um
they have
a procurement process for companies to
enter their system pitch the government
uh six to nine months
sometimes it's longer to get in there so
usually it's when moments like this
happen if they're not in the system a
new competitor that's what i'm cur i'm
concerned maybe about some of these like
rural broadband offerings we have like
ancient companies who you know the new
new tech hasn't necessarily done the
procurement process across states right
there's a lot of them to do you know
state by state wi-fi and fiber optics
and things like that
but basically you're investing
what we're doing is investing in state
leadership i think like they're going to
be the ones that put this stuff to work
and
i'm gonna make a call
because i'm one for one since we started
forward podcast called the
call of philosophy will uh i think the
red red state governor's gonna be better
at this than the blue state governors um
because a lot of it is what this is
people like oh anti-pro-business i don't
like these pro-business candidates fair
fair points to that but
a lot of the job is to evaluate
companies and their ability to execute
and then oversee their project that's a
lot of what being a governor is where
you're writing these checks i don't know
what your thoughts are on that um in
terms of who's going to implement this
on a in a better more effective way i
don't know well i think a lot of the
money naturally is going to flow to the
blue states because they have a higher
population density
needs yeah you know like just the bulk
of the money is going to go to
um to the coasts and in my mind yes uh
just you know math and
the rest of it but i 100 agree with you
that there's a massive government
efficiency argument to be made that
democrats are losing
uh and uh you know it's it's to me one
of the hazards of essentially one party
rule is that if you have
a very blue
state or uh city then there's no
meaningful competition and then you wind
up with a lot of self-dealing and
corruption and then no one really comes
to them and is like hey that was a
boondoggle i mean you can see that there
are boondoggles all over you know
governments of both kinds but i would
tend to agree with you that if you have
um
environments where
uh where where folks are a bit more
mindful of efficiency and things are
less political then you'd see some
output results yeah i agree that where
it's
you got to think there's a republican or
democratic establishment right and if
you're only staying in the republican
lane or the democratic lane you end up
with no
need or ability to change right you end
up with the same company same
relationships same donors or republican
party that sort of thing so
um
going to be fascinating watch my other
question for you is on the politics of
this because i think that's um
well i i will say too too zack is that
at this point now the infrastructure
bill has been passed everything is going
to turn to
the reconciliation bill yeah the social
infrastructure better call it build back
better the 1.75 trillion dollar
uh act and one of the interesting
dynamics is that a lot of
representatives don't really want to
vote on it because it's just going to
get smashed into something different at
the senate anyway
you know
it's important really we should know
that uh this is going to be a senate
driven bill and that means it's going to
be a joe manchin and kirsten cinema
driven bill uh and so there are a lot of
dems are like look why are we going to
stick our knicks out and
put the sun the moon and the stars into
this bill um when it's just gonna get
thrown out anyway now there are some
folks with political incentives to throw
the sun moon and stars into the house
bill because they can like be like we
fought for it right though
they know it's gonna get tossed out and
then there are more moderate democrats
who are like i really don't want to have
like the attack ads saying i asked for
the sun and the moon the stars and i
know we're not going to get some of
those things right so so that is the
political set of incentives around uh
build back better uh where some folks
are going to posture and say like hey we
put all the stuff in uh
and that that's to really like you know
frankly um
please their base
uh i'll give you an example of something
that you know that you can have
different opinions about um but they're
trying to put immigration reform into
build back better right and then the
senate parliamentarian the rules person
was like hey this is a budget bill and
so you can't can't do that yeah uh and
so some democrats are like we're gonna
put it in there anyway even though they
know there's like a 90 illegal yeah nine
percent chance gonna get tossed out um
and then some of the moderate democrats
are like why do i really want to throw
myself on this one given that i know
there's a 99 chance that it's gonna get
thrown out
um so
that so the politics are going to shift
toward the reconciliation bill and one
of the main reasons why the
infrastructure bill took forever to pass
was because progressives were
essentially holding the infrastructure
bill hostage
to try and get
the
uh you know the moderates to
support for
um the bigger reconciliation package now
infrastructure is passed and uh the
momentum and i will say this is
something that some people are concerned
about the momentum towards
buildback better is still there
despite the loss in virginia um i think
in large part because
everyone knows that this is the biden
agenda right and so if you're uh
moderate democrat you still want to
see to it that you have
um some points on the board
um so so just for because this was not
clear to me and i follow this relatively
closely there there are two bills one we
just passed which is the infrastructure
bill and that is everything i just
listed off and it's pretty bipartisan oh
yeah very vibrant
19 republican senators as well yeah so
that was it yeah and it's 13
so that's a i'll get in that sec so then
there's what we're talking about is the
buildback better plan which is going to
be passed on our budget reconciliation
process
that is so the infrastructure bill was
separate was 1.2 trillion
uh this one is 1.75 trillion right now
it's a different bill and that has a lot
of things that dems have claimed to be
fighting for but can never get there um
let's get the party to line up for call
it paid family leave
and
uh i have a whole list of the stuff
that's in this uh you've got paid family
leave you've got uh like negotiating
prescription drug prices for medicare
you've got a whole bunch of things that
are more progressive more pro-family
more social safety net such
um on the infrastructure bill 13
republican house members came across the
aisle
and all of your usual suspects of
progressives got to do their virtual
signaling performative empathy whereas
that's what our guys on the inside were
saying it's a win for
it's a loss for kevin mccarthy and
republicans but a win for pelosi because
she got a bipartisan bill and she let
all of her progressives on the far left
aoc elon omar the usual corey bush to
use the suspects
they got to say we're not for this
because this is corporatists or whatever
they get to go on young turks and say
how awesome and progressive they are um
but for what it's worth like the
progressives that i think you and i
probably have more alignment like your
katie porters and your rokanas they were
all for this um
so
the question for you is on the buildback
better plan
how much the performance is still going
to happen
do you in your opinion um or do you
think we actually you kind of alluded
this but do you think we end up lining
up on the buildback better plan the the
real question for everyone is what
stays and what goes yeah um because they
originally had a
bill that was twice the size 3.5
trillion uh and some of the things that
you named are now in the cutting room
floor it looks like paid family leave
may not make it in it looks like
medicare uh drug price negotiation may
not make it in you've got public housing
there you get universal pre-k
so the question is what what makes it in
and again it's going to be a mansion
cinema
determination what stays in
on this one i think the pressure is
going to be reversed where every
progressive is going to vote for it and
uh they're going to try and cajole the
moderates to thank you for more and more
uh and it looks like everyone's aligned
that this thing has to pass in some form
um the the political incentives are
different for the reps because again a
lot of the stuff's going to get massaged
and changed at the senate level
um so
uh
i think that they're going they have a
lot of work to do uh the the senate has
a lot of work to do by year end uh that
the hope is that they can get this thing
done by then um but you should see the
house negotiations proceed and they're
gonna send something to the senate um
hopefully
you know like before your end
uh
the the
thing i'm most excited about is that it
looks like the child tax credit is there
to stay it's not yeah it's not like an
eternal
renewal which i would love
but it is a one-year renewal um and i
suppose in the current environment
you've got to take that as a as a win um
you know at this point you're going to
be in place for
a year and a half
uh and if you have a year and a half of
families getting
you know three six hundred dollar checks
uh i think it's going to be very hard
at the end of 2022 to be like and you
know that stuff that actually has been
doing great like yeah yeah enough of
that so
i'm pumped that the child tax credit is
here to stay it's exciting we're going
to spike the football this happens let
me ask you this
i don't know about bill back better yet
but
for
comparison the infrastructure bill just
passed was
2702 pages
i want to put that in context that's uh
more than half of the entire harry
potter series
um all books combined that is
double the size of war and peace and the
entire lord of the rings trilogy
and these things happen like
over a weekend right over a night so
do you think anyone actually read it
well infrastructure is uh is something
where they've been developing these
plans for years and years and years
essentially lying on the shelf where
someone thought at some point it's like
look when it's infrastructure time i'm
ready what do we want to do what do we
want to do i mean you know we've all
heard of infrastructure week it's been
infrastructure week for
years and years
so this is an area where there's there's
going to be some well-developed thinking
and planning uh because it's been lying
in weight for
realistically decades right i mean you
do have you gotta think you've got a ton
of congress members they've got staff
tons of staff they can break it down
summarize most of them are lawyers are
used to this crap so i do think like
people have an idea of what's
interacting that we'll pull over it's
one reason why infrastructure again we
all like it is because the stuff is
pretty real
like they're you know there are plans
like you know i mean that they
um
the engineering
uh
society of america has been analyzing
this stuff for years like we kind of
know
we've known for a while that we were
kind of crumbling
yeah so i i'm i'm pumped i think most
americans should be pumped i'm pumped
too
[Music]
it's a tough time right now a lot of us
are down a lot of us feel like you know
a little sluggish the days are getting
shorter despite daylight savings time
etc etc and a lot of times you think hey
i'd like to talk to someone but you
don't want to bug your friends your
family the fact is no one wants to hear
anyone complain honestly it's kind of
like
the way the world so what do you do
betterhelp.com
gets you in touch with a professional
therapist who will be your mental health
resource on demand i think of it as uber
for mental health i hope that's a good
metaphor for people i hope that's
appealing to you because better help
works it's awesome
take charge of your mental health don't
just let yourself be down and at the
extremes this can actually be very very
serious like being depressed is a
serious thing you do not have to suffer
in silence go to betterhelp.com today
live a happier life and as a listener
you'll get 10 off your first month by
visiting our sponsor at betterhelp.com
yang i believe in better help join over
1 million people who have taken charge
of their mental health every day again
that's betterhelp help.com
treat yourself right the people around
you will be glad you did
[Music]
well here's the the thing that democrats
are missing in a very very very big way
um which is this uh
i think it was michael schuman of
politico who said that we're in the
post-modern era of governing where uh
it's not how you actually govern it's
the appearance of how you govern oh yeah
because the truth get in the way of a
good story well one of the things that
that happened too is when uh
is that people's perception of the
economy at this point
is based upon whether their team is
winning uh like that like there was a
period when trump
won
uh the election and then all republicans
thought the economy was better even
though he hadn't taken office yet and
literally like nothing had changed but
everyone was like oh now we're thrilled
yeah we're
and so
what democrats missed in a very very big
way is that uh what that is that they
just sent this message that they weren't
on the same team and they were just
bickering
and it was like all political posturing
and a lot of the country at this point
was like oh oh no like this is not what
we need uh and then
even if you pass the bill frankly it's
not like anyone's gonna see some you
know magical new bridge highway airport
for
like months and months i mean we're
talking about literally maybe after the
midterms are 22
that someone might see something
and so what they what they missed was
really what derek thompson called like
the vibes war is that they they
completely lost the vibes war they lost
the fives for yeah i love that and now
that now they're gonna turn around and
be like but we passed it but we passed
it and it's like
at this point a lot of it's like well
you already kind of blamed you sort of
established a vibe that you know a lot
of people aren't crazy about and then
you do pass it and then like this
literally could have been an enormous
looking victory two months ago yes but
just if you drag this three months ago
but if you drag this thing out like this
then it's like harder to
generate that sense of victory
because you know like the average
american again is not going to see her
feel this uh for for months and months
it's interesting to watch because you
look at these 2021 races but they're not
midterms but political press is dreaming
ginning up a bunch of
outrage over upcoming elections right
these elections come down the pike and
the dems aren't looking good looking
like we're going to lose seats we're not
supposed to and so there's this rhetoric
from the democrats are like it's cause
we can't pass a bill it's because we
can't do x y because we're getting
nothing done but then i also see from
prominent democratic
on the far left per se but private
democratic leaders and spokespersons
that
um or critics that are like well we
don't once they do pass the builder like
oh it doesn't do enough or it's not
great or this is corporatist or this
sort of thing are democrats impossible
to please um or is this like are we in a
is this kind of what you've said before
this is like if there's no conflict
nothing's happening so we have to find
conflict over over anything well the
issue is that you essentially have two
parties like lodged into the democratic
party at this point that's true uh and
so the the two parties are going to have
very very different points of view and
you're seeing this play out over and
over again buffalo you know yeah your
town is an emblem of this
um and so
you know what what's funny is i
obviously think that we should have more
political parties and then we should
have a system where these people are not
in the same party um progressives will
very much dislike that argument because
they think to themselves no we're going
to take over the democratic party um and
uh you know like we're gonna win this
thing from within
um i i'm not sure if that's the way it's
going to play out
um but
in my view we'd be better off if the
democratic party were two parties the
republican party was two parties and
most people on the left would agree with
me at the republican party because then
you would have a group of uh anti-trump
republicans or like uh you know like you
you can tell that there are like the
trump republicans and then the
non-trump republicans and the major
problem is that the non-trump
republicans have to act like trump
republicans in order to keep their jobs
and so so you have like that that me and
so i think anyone on the left would be
like oh yeah i'd love to the republican
party where two parties um and then
i think the democratic party should be
two parties as well and you'd have you
know more genuine um negotiations and
exchanges uh but that's why you're going
to see very different communications out
of certain actors in the left because
there are folks on the left who will say
you know like this it doesn't go far
enough
um
and that would i think be very a very
consistent message from them almost
regardless of what uh what gets passed
because a lot of things they want um are
dramatic which you know i think most
people know like i'm for some dramatic
things too so you know like i don't
necessarily think that incrementalism
should like win the day every time
[Laughter]
i think the other thing is um
i'm just curious of the timeline so
we're freaking out saying he didn't get
anything done didn't get anything done
but they got something done by
november early november in his first
year in office
i guess i would say for context barack
obama and that administration passed the
affordable care act in march of his
second year
um now he had a financial crisis the
other thing taking our attention but i
also wonder if this like 24-hour news
cycle that's only accelerated since 2009
is driving us to say you're not doing
anything when in reality these things
actually take a longer time i don't know
i i think that there were some genuine
missteps in this process and people did
complain that it's like look joe didn't
ask us to vote joe didn't put his foot
down joe didn't have like a clear
directive or vision
uh and i i genuinely think that there
were missteps you know like so here's
here's my my read on what's going on um
some of the stuff that uh joe biden is
taking heat for
you know like
not really uh under his control but like
have there been some
errors that where you'd look at and say
oh like you know you wish you'd been
uh a bit stronger on that you wish that
he'd
i'll use afghanistan as an example it's
like decision decision to withdraw
most americans agree with that
um the execution most all of us can see
that there were some problems and like
later the military commanders were like
yeah this is not yeah they line up yeah
yeah there's not you know and and so
you know but then when asked about it
joe essentially it was like you know
both these was the plan yeah like the
plan was the plan and it was perfect and
all the generals agreed even though like
you know later generals were like no no
not not really like we all kind of know
that there was some shiny execution
there yeah uh and so
uh so on this one
uh was there the equivalent of shoddy
execution in terms of getting your party
on the same page and like getting a
thing passed before the midterms yes
yeah uh
and so you know like that those are this
is part of the vibes war thing i think
is is that like the like the the biden
vibes have not been great um they're
different people there's someone who you
know this is another issue but like
someone complained to me that joe hasn't
yet appointed an ambassador to china um
which seems like an important
relationship and so yeah so so someone
you know like they nominate andrew yang
although we do not want that job uh you
know they maybe they want that yeah they
wouldn't appoint me for a number of
reasons but mandarin sucks that's the
biggest reason but but that would be
better than mine but yeah
i'm sorry that's a prerequisite i mean i
don't know i don't know
get some google translate action in
there so um so there are different
things that
different people take this
administration to task with yeah and i
think some of those things are you know
like legitimate
here's my quit another question for you
i'm peppering with questions this is fun
maybe it's part of my job here um
is this a problem with not
with running an anti-candidate platform
as a party right instead of like we
don't like joe biden does not have call
it the populist love
or like the love of the people
he won as we many would agree with was
that most people were anti-biden or
anti-trump more than they were pro-joe
and when you're an executive leadership
function in politics
it's easier to put your foot down
if you're like if you don't line up i'm
coming to your state and i'm going to
support your challenger in 2022 or
wherever you're at the midterms are you
know obama was able to do that if he had
to you know trump still is able to do
that and he's no longer in power or at
least elected
is that is that like the core of this
right or is it just that you know is it
joe himself not being effective leader
is his age i don't know
here's my read so uh joe wins wins the
popular vote uh you know
like doesn't have like a you know
storming mandate but he comes in and
there is a honeymoon uh you know his
approval rating is about fifty percent
and yeah yeah yeah
okay we're into it
uh
and and now
that that early capital has been lost
his approval rating is at 43 percent
lower among independents so he can't go
and really bully folks uh now what do
they care politically yeah uh you know
there's some candidates who i don't
think they they feel like his
um
you know his ability to uplift them is
is that strong
um that's tough
oh you know but it's still
the leader and and so democrats are like
well you know we have to try and support
him and and get back to that point
uh i think that there is going to be a
massive set of problems though for
democrats moving forward because they
ran against trump and this is part of
the binary dynamic uh and i i don't
disagree with some of this stuff but
that they they ran on the sun and the
moon and the stars
and then
they did you know and it was really kind
of like good versus evil like you know
get rid of the bad guy we're going to
come in and uh
better he's
all this great stuff's going to happen
and then a lot of people are like hey
this hasn't really been happening and a
lot of people are exhausted a lot of
people are very demotivated and
de-energized you can see that in the
virginia new jersey elections where it's
like you know like the democrats have
real
kind of fatigue and disillusionment
setting in and then the energy is very
much behind the other side yeah so does
this continue for another 12 months into
2022
unclear but
but i would certainly bet i think most
people now would would bet on
republicans taking the house and maybe
the senate at this rate and then at that
point the culture in dc becomes
uh gridlock central
fun
again but this is to me
quite likely
um
in part because
that it's been
difficult to pin down the democratic
message
um aside from again
trump uh the worst and
kovid and then neither of those things
will work now
i think they get it they're gonna get it
done they'll get a buildback better plan
done of some sort and that'll be a good
legacy win for joe i don't know if it's
good enough to win in 2022 for the
midterms and 2024 but
legacy wise i think good for the united
states generally speaking depending what
happens in buildback i yeah i like a lot
of the stuff in buildback better and i
mean again love the child tax credit and
there are a lot of other things i like
too there's a lot there's a lot of
things i don't like i mean you know
there's certain things i just don't
think of it's great at but we're going
to find out um
let me say this the one thing i'm
curious about this too is
i think bill back better is such a
terrible name and i think democrats are
terrible at naming things generally
speaking they are subpar naming things
yeah can you have better names um
yeah i always thought that uh party
should come up this was bill clinton's
thing he said
if he was in power
i think he was talking about the trump
election not gonna find this um but he
said i would call it the american
comeback plan
better which is way better but the thing
is
build back better is so team democrat
built back better it's that vibe it's
also triple b it's like it's
alliteration which is [ __ ] if
anything you'd want to be you'd want to
be rated triple a you know what i mean
like who the hell wants to get like the
triple b rating yeah we want the b plan
um
and it's uh this is the key guys key to
naming things and andrew and i have done
had these conversations many times i
would name it uh something around values
american comeback is good
some something around uh you know
fairness like uh fairness for families
like some something but that that's
actually too dummy too yeah that's a
little different i discard more i get
where you're going where it's like uh uh
some sort of justice or uh
because fair enough american sense that
[ __ ] is rigged and that it's super
unfair and so if you were to be like
look we're gonna
make it right like that this is like uh
you know an investment in families
uh which is a lot of what's in there
yeah well one of the keys to naming
things and you and i done this a lot is
use it in a sentence
the way other people you find a way that
other people would use this name in a
sentence and decide if you like that or
not because particularly in politics
that's how it's going to work
so when you have reporters or supporters
being we love the buildback better plan
like that doesn't sound great it sounds
stupid it sounds team
damn no matter what
uh
and frankly you're going to win by
probably
getting some form
my off the cuff suggestion was literally
triple f fairness for families
which that now i think about it that
that
deserves an f i don't know
um we were brainstorming we're throwing
we're
we're [ __ ] on this without a
particular i mean i said america come
back bam we don't have a lot of other
options acp is not bad that's not bad
that's pretty good um
my point was like for example i just
think republicans generally speaking are
better at naming things
and
but obama was good at naming things too
so i thought affordable care act was
fine not great but fine
like good enough to be like using a
sentence and like be like palatable
republicans so republicans said screw
that we're calling it obamacare and i'll
give obama credit it was like [ __ ] yeah
it's got my name in it i love that you
give my legacy a tied to like the first
major healthcare plan in the united
states ever um
so
uh and it was like solidified him so i
think you know um but also it was easy
for republicans to [ __ ] on when he threw
obama's name on it right and it didn't
win per se but it was uh helpful for
them so anyway something to think about
yeah so the the the things that it's
been called are terrible names um no
one's gonna get excited about the
reconciliation plan i mean that that's
just a process name um social
infrastructure also sounds very made up
so american comeback more visceral
better who doesn't like a good comeback
you could uh i mean hell do they if
they're talking about printing money
there's a million american marketing
firms that come up with 20 names that
would accomplish various goals that's
what they could pay to do so democrats
generally just need to invest more in
this stuff yes they're losing the vibes
war they're losing the marketing war
you know and one of the things i said
after virginia is like that after they
lose they just like blame the voters
it's really like the weirdest set of
behaviors there was an article that said
like um you know democrats are
agonizing over their loss and will
change nothing
you know that that was like like the
the general oh we'll miss the point
where it's like like we talk about
critical race theory crt being taught in
schools and like generally speaking it's
not
being like baked into curriculums on a
formal level or anything like that
but if you like go one layer deeper like
parents are upset because they feel like
politics is bleeding into their
classrooms right where teachers are even
forced or saying to make political
decisions and no one likes that um and
then the people who vote for
one side get berated as racist yeah and
then you know then they tune out yeah
they're like well you know i can't trust
you call me that and um yeah so
anyway here we are um buildback better
you gotta think of your name all right
moving on you could call it like name
[ __ ] better
this name sucks pacifism
that might be better actually
[Music]
i wanted to bring this up andrew because
it was such a fun case study of
automation
i think i'm going to say gone wrong
because it definitely like there was
like you know it definitely blew up for
zillow but you know the net
situation here is even more interesting
so
well this story before you go that this
is
2021 capitalism to a t yeah yes yes i'm
so so
i'll summarize and then we'll get your
thoughts on how was that that's probably
better because you're gonna have more
intelligent things to say so zillow
you guys are familiar with zillow
because you'd stalk your friends
anytime you visit a place you're like
how much does that work it up on zillow
right i remember driving through parts
of new york like what's it cost to have
a house out here like so low right um
but you could also when you're looking
to buy a home zillow is
a great place to go they get a ton
millions and millions and billions
actually but people go on their website
um it's not just you it's not jeep it's
all of us and so they had something
called zestimates it's an estimate with
a z in front of it very that's actually
not bad marketing anyway uh that's
that's great i mean i i've looked at
zest i liked his estimates yeah for sure
um and so they've never been hyper
accurate i mean when they first started
they were wrong like all the time like
barely right 75 percent of time now
they're within like two percent accurate
which is a lot in investing but for you
trying to get a ballpark of a
neighborhood or a house it's wonderful
sure it's great um
but basically zillow
uh
want to get some more money than just
selling ads so the way that they make a
lot of their money is basically selling
why would i help you buy houses when i
can just buy the houses myself
i'm gonna borrow hundreds of millions of
dollars billions of dollars and buy
houses at bulk smarter and then
flip them and then make mega bucks
because you know i wasn't making enough
mega bucks before i have to grow to the
moon i have to go to the moon and so
let's do this thing i buying is that is
that a real term high buying is a real
term look at that i'd buy it online like
assets that are hard to buy usually buy
in person they're now some are moving
online so they instead of their core
business which was basically selling hot
leads
to
mortgage and real estate uh brokers
they started basically getting into real
estate themselves what could go wrong
but let's buy the houses ourselves and
turn around and flip them we know the
market better than everyone else you
have access to super money well if i'm
fair like if you're sitting in the room
the board room or let me just management
teams a zillow you're like
i could drink that kool-aid you're like
we're the biggest real estate player in
the world right you're right i'm being a
little bit harsh because the fact is
there are several firms doing this like
this is this is an industry and it's not
just a zillow right so they take their
zestimates and their life and also some
of the big private equity firms have
been making a case yeah they're all
doing this right and so they buy and
basically concept you buy it
where you think it's worth make them
minor repairs and you flip them and the
hardest part if anyone's worked in real
estate is that real estate is expensive
to own there's insurance there's taxes
there's repairs there's utilities
there's all this crap so you have to
flip it fast um
and so basically zillow
they [ __ ] up like they
didn't do this well and here's the
numbers so
they bought 10 000 homes in the third
quarter of 2021 this quarter which is
double what they did in the second
quarter and they were hiring a ton of
humans to basically like they'd buy it
with the algorithm
or they'd want to buy the algorithm
there'd be people vetting it
internally and then there'd be local
real estate agents also vetting the deal
as well and so they hired two like 2 500
people
in the first nine months of this year to
like build this out but eventually they
bought too many houses uh and they had
to sell a bunch of them and they they
went out so thoughts on this i mean you
can dive in more in terms of mechanics
of this but zillow
automated the home buying process and
then lost let me give you the exact
number it was like
500 569 million dollars uh was there
like quoted lost thirty thousand dollars
a home they bought in over ten thousand
homes they purchased
thoughts
again this is really just capitalism
today where it's like you've got a
business you're making money you got to
grow go grow and you're touching
massive pools of
capital for sure
and if you've got
access to that kind of money and you're
like okay like how do we deploy this why
why are we letting other people make
money off of our information instead of
making it ourselves
in a way it's like a version of vertical
integration there are other firms that
we're doing this
so if you were to defend zillow you'd
say well you could argue while they have
no choice but to do it because there are
other firms that you have to grow
um the knock on it would be like hey
uh
holding these houses if you're off by
even a little bit you could
really punish you financially very very
quickly because if you're one percent
off over
10 000 homes you know over a three-month
period like you know that could add up
to a lot which is apparently what
happened
so
you know you could say this is just an
algo execution problem then if they just
gotten the math right
uh then they'd be okay
um you could look at this and say
um maybe there are limits to what you
can do with online uh with automation
yeah just kind of you know maybe there's
something specific about
uh a house
that uh makes it more than just like a a
mathematical calculation
um or that this market is so
um
this market is so dynamic that uh you
you would need incredible reserves uh if
you're off by like a a little bit right
um and you know at scale like if you're
off on like you know 10 houses it's one
thing if you're often ten thousand
houses then um and then it's another and
there is an emotional aspect to the real
estate market
uh where we can see right now that
there's some froth in certain places and
it's
you know they're like national patterns
that are playing out in particular ways
uh you know i have friends who have
real estate in florida and it's just
been like the most berserk market known
to man
down there you know it's like like
parents live in florida hello has it
happened i've got a soft spot for
florida but they're like vacant lots
that have gone up two to three times in
value just like for you know just
because they're they're in your you know
the water or whatever or hot market near
a hot market who knows yeah so
uh
but this is
the the kind of combination of
automation and
vast capital
uh and the competitive aspect in some of
these
industries where you're going to see
stuff like this
more and more and and i will suggest too
that
we are in a very frothy time
uh and uh and you're seeing occasional
blow-ups
uh now it's not enough to stop the
mega momentum i i talked to an investor
friend who who was very concerned about
the climate um and then evelyn asked
well it's like so are you going to cash
um if you're so concerned about the
climate and by the way he works in real
estate um and then he was like you can't
go to cash or else you go out of
business so you know we just go
um and so i think that's where we are
right now where a lot of people can see
that we're going to go off the edge of
you know a cliff or the top of a wave or
whatever but you can't get off right now
if your incentives are to grow grow and
make money as much as you can
um
that's where we are in november 2021 in
andrew yang's opinion so
you know you can take that for what it's
worth um but i think you're going to see
a lot more like the zillow
blow up
in the days to come
so a couple thoughts one that scale to
go to tens of thousands of homes
hiring almost 3 000 people i'm sure they
had more private contractors and
part-time employees in nine months is
ridiculous that i don't care how big of
a company you are that is a massive
undertaking um because we hired a couple
hundred in a month and it was wild um
which you would you need to be at a
faster scale frankly um
so that's one but um what's crazy me
andrew is
my takeaway in this
the most mind-blowing part of this
entire thing is that zillow's gonna be
fine oh yeah this is like
this is some pain but then they
completely botched this up
lost half a billion dollars not more and
they're gonna be fine their apps and
websites had almost three billion
visits in the third quarter their online
marketing business is on pace to go 34
this year and there's a strong housing
market um
and the other thing is the ceo like has
basically in a situation where he owns
certain types of shares where they're
not going to oust him at least in the
short run
so what's the market capital uh i don't
know let's look it up
what do you think guess that line i'm
i'm going to guess 20 billion yeah low
tons of billions 16.6 billion oh that's
pretty cool that's not bad not good for
prices right but not bad zach to be yeah
well you said 20 billion we'll take that
low tens of billions we're there look at
us we can do this uh
so
yeah they'll be fine no problem i mean
their stocks down they'll be fine
weather the storm um
you had talked about the fourth
industrial revolution and a whole bunch
of things we're running for president
but there is like a limit to the fourth
industrial revolution where there are
certain things that need a human or at
least will for the foreseeable future
um
do you think
in the this is actually an interesting
question in the big five top five job
categories you talked to or
call center is it clerical work
administration you got truck driving
number four retail food service of food
prep manufacturing
is there any that's gonna hit that human
wall that kind of zillow hit in real
estate
uh i think you're going to see
those things get automated more and more
um the where what is the human wall you
know this is going to be this is going
to be tough you know it's like i i think
a lot of the jobs that we imagine to be
the most human are actually the most
prone to automation and what i'm going
to throw out there as like my number one
example
is uh therapy and mental health
that it turns out military veterans are
more comfortable talking to a therapy
bot than a real-life human therapist uh
and the efficacy is comparable and
certainly you can triage to a human if
you know someone's suicidal so uh you
know but a lot of people will be like oh
you need a human being for therapy it's
like
you actually like
an ai is better in some ways wow um so
and so you can extrapolate that you know
another thing i'm going to throw out
there too
uh healthcare yeah um which is a lot of
the stuff that you want to do for
healthcare is fairly
mechanical and rules based you know what
i mean like we talk about bedside manner
and like doctors and nurses and all that
stuff like a lot of us we want you to do
certain things there was a company
there was a number of years ago um their
one innovation is they got nurses to
call patients and just try and change
their behavior uh and that was enough
for them to become like a really big
successful company because so much of it
was around if you could get people to
change their behaviors then you can get
them to be healthier and you save a lot
of money interesting in various ways the
patient behave differently so a lot of
this is behavior modification and i
think technology can really help with
behavior modification in a way that's
more realistic than a person
uh
yes so um you know so those are my two
cents on it um one thing i will say that
i think that the human touch is vital
for
personal training like you know if
you've ever had a personal trainer
whether the gym gives you one for free
or whatnot you're like i don't need a
trainer i know my [ __ ] and then you get
one all of a sudden you're like ah
you know i will i will say have you have
you looked at tonal
it's pretty awesome no no no this is not
to say i have not also enjoyed the
fruits of automated uh trainers and
fitness apps and whatnot yeah they're
they're pretty good and
like they they'll do
70 percent of the job you know i agree
it's a human touch there is it's
important um
but tonal is pretty sick it's like
customized to your body weight and where
you performed last time and total hasn't
even sponsored us totally not sponsored
right like you know and that's a big
part of it um
i'm
i do think this is this is where
this is what the rubber meets about
meets the road and we have no idea where
like actually the one to me is like
feels like driving is going to be like
slower than you think yeah it's tough to
automate driving or people or just like
it's like this human trust thing but
it's not as black and white as you think
because you'd think a therapist would
imply trust right like i have but the
reality is you're actually just getting
stuff off your chest the only trust you
need is that they don't freaking tell
anybody or hold things against you and
judge you um
what your computer can do well to the
extent that the human wall
is going to be tough to overcome and we
shouldn't make it seem like humanity's a
barrier in this way um but it is in my
mind a lot of fine motor stuff in
difficult settings yeah uh and one
example i used to use is like you know
if you need to clean a hotel room you'd
much rather human than a robot because
we're always going to look there and be
like you know what the hell's you know
it's like all these like random things
um and so you're gonna have humans doing
things
um in that context for a long time i
think food prep
is is in there like you can automate
aspects of it um but like some of the
fine motor stuff uh you know you'll
you'll have humans take a long time yeah
hairdressing some of the examples
um
hair dryers for sure because edward
scissorhands terrifying yeah i know
everyone wants to get it it's near your
face but like the other parts of it
maybe
i don't know massages i don't i don't
know it's gonna be interesting it's a
tough time man because like the the like
i can see ai and technology uh you know
getting more and more and and like the
the vision we have of capitalism where
it's like oh start a small business we
work hard we compete like now so much of
that stuff's getting wrecked i mean you
know if you're
an individual mom and pop investor and
then zillow is coming around throwing
around billions of dollars like buying
you know i mean like the economy's just
flowing more and more to these mega
actors there's like this consolidation
at the top
uh and it's it's something that
our government really just does not
understand at all because they'll just
make arguments around principles
on the market meanwhile you have
trillion dollar companies trillion
dollar companies that are defying every
law of business physics it's like like
you said it's like they can [ __ ] up
doesn't matter you know they have access
to what tim o'reilly called super money
it's like as soon as you touch the super
money then there are no more business
laws of gravity anymore yes you do what
you want yeah you do what you want and
you know we all can think of the
companies that have that super money
i'll tell you another area where the
super money is changing everything just
movies and content production you
remember the good old days when there
are movie studios and it's like oh they
had like the special sauce and it's like
oh i could make a moving cream you had
to be smart with what you invested in
you got one or two big blockbusters a
year yeah and it mattered if the movie
succeeded or failed right now
you have amazon apple netflix just
throwing billions of dollars my favorite
example on this space was that chris
pratt movie tomorrow war that amazon
bought yep
evan i watched if you haven't seen it
it's really i really like it yeah yeah
it's like you settle down you're like oh
it's to be a random sci-fi movie you're
like oh this is actually like a quality
hollywood production
so they spent 200 million dollars on uh
tomorrow war and then because of you
know covet circumstance and whatnot they
just turned around and just sold it to
amazon for
200 million dollars
it was just like a like a complete just
like zero
gain swap it's like look we made this
movie we don't want to take the heat for
releasing and trying to make the money
back so here you go and then amazon's
like we will zero out your investment
and then it just shows up on our tvs
for essentially free minimal marketing
i think i saw a couple ads maybe like
subway or something but not you know
they're just like here it is yeah so so
now content has become like an add-on
for these tech platforms
and tech has become the tail that's
wagging the dog
uh so you know content itself is getting
kind of sanded down i almost tweeted
something i was like we're all content
now um you know there was that bo
burnham thing where it's like hey maybe
compressing all of human experience to
to like the
the algorithm like might not be such a
good idea
yeah so so that stuff's definitely
happening
uh
and
again like you know our leadership
doesn't really understand so content's
the clearest one where that stuff's
getting uh
commoditized and automated but you can
see that happening more and more and
again i'm going to suggest that most
people think that content like film and
whatnot
artistry
humanity
emotion like that stuff irreplaceable
it's like no no it turns out that i can
just [ __ ]
like yeah you know get the money get the
talent get the algorithm see what it is
you like you know like send it down send
it down your gullet and oh by the way if
i don't make money don't care yeah
the one that to me it's gonna change
everything and i don't know i don't know
when we'll get there i actually don't
know if but this is a big one where it's
there's a certain level what it's like
the business trust that i'm kind of as a
catch-all where it's all right you have
no problem spending 20 bucks for an
automated service uh 50 bucks or buying
something online you buy like you
a thousand dollar suit you may buy
online you might buy a thousand a pair
of shoes 500 pair shoes whatever it is
you may buy a car right 50 000 80 000
right without touching a human right um
but there's a certain level everybody's
got different where it's a big enough
purchase where you wouldn't do it online
um
and
for now it's probably somewhere between
a car and a home you know
and give and take on both sides but if
you look at a lot of business nowadays
is like
taking a company public or big mergers
and acquisitions or buying a new office
building or whatever these massive
investments people want that human
or wealth management good example like i
want to invest all my money in this i
kind of want a human to
tell me it's going to be okay or give me
some experience
at some point i think it computes me
able to do that stuff because the job's
not that hard i've worked in that space
and wealth management but i don't know i
don't know if humans you see the comfort
level just going up and up man yeah you
know you see something like betterment
or
wealth
yeah like like a while ago you wouldn't
have believed that but now everyone's
cool with it yeah
not everyone but younger people are cool
with it agreed and that's the other
thing but my you know the younger
generations keep growing up more used to
it and then it changes right um
so
anytime someone says here's my takeaway
i don't know if you agree this anyone
anytime someone says you'll always need
a human to do x
what are they wrong eighty percent of
the time well certainly certainly you
you you should examine whether they have
some vested interest yeah and
having that be true uh you know because
80 of americans think that most jobs
will be automated but but they also
don't think their job is going to be
automated this is the way our minds work
there's no way they're automating
podcasters you know oh definitely not
know what yeah two percent chance
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right i want to shift to this
because it's pretty crazy and
the press did not really do this justice
i don't think twitter did this just
either the university of austin new
university starting by
our friend barry weissen and crew
um
to combat what the hell is going on in
our universities right now in the united
states of america so we can break this
down but thoughts on this um
thoughts on her move thoughts on that
this will work that's about why i can
break down some stats too but when we
start you well i i just love that people
are building something and uh trying to
do it better you know one of the real
issues in american life is we're all
just starting to get very very negative
about things like institutions and be
like oh you know the media oh you know
like schools uh you name it um and then
someone
like barry and a lot of other people uh
uh peter burgosians one of the founding
faculty members right uh there are you
know dozens of people probably hundreds
you know dozens we've heard of and
hundreds that we probably uh you know
just don't know who they are
um just wanna actually put their money
where their mouth is and say hey we
think we can do a better job we think
there's a need we can fill it uh you
know that's what i'm doing with a
forward party that's what i think that
our this movement's been about in large
part it's like we can do better we can
build better build better sorry but it's
built back better yeah but it's
it's like build a better mousetrap you
know it's like like the
the the moment you stop complaining and
start doing something about it then in
my mind i've always felt much more
positive and upbeat and healthier
because when you complain
um it there's like a kind of negative
sentiment that creeps up because you're
like oh that sucks this sucks
and then at some point you have to be
like well if it really does suck
maybe i can offer the world a better
alternative and oh by the way if i'm
right
maybe there's an immense opportunity
there maybe there's a ton of value glad
you're wired that way most people aren't
they like to complain
and so that's the way i saw the
university of austin is like okay there
are people that are
sad about something that's going on in
existing universities and you know like
i've said it's like why is it that
college is two and a half times more
expensive than it was when i went to
school did it get two and a half times
better we know it did not
so what's really going on i mean i think
a lot of americans sense that uh that
these organizations have just started to
you know serve themselves in various
ways i think this is a major major
critique of the democratic party is that
among the things that are making
americans the most miserable it would be
education and health care costs
and
we don't do enough to rein those in i
think health care is now up to 18
percent of gdp
uh you're not seeing better results you
know you're seeing higher costs same
thing with a lot of the education little
institutions so if a group of people
think they can offer a better product
and you know i mean i don't know if what
like it might not be for like less money
but who cares you know it's like if you
offer something better to the world all
to the good uh i'm excited about it so
here's the stats they region then i'll
tell you my comments up uh nearly a
quarter of american academics in the
social scientists or humanities endorsed
endorse ousting a colleague for having a
wrong opinion about a hot button issue
such as immigration or gender
differences
a quarter of professors want the firing
people for the wrong opinion
a third of conservative academics and
phd students say they've been threatened
with discipline disciplinary action for
their views four or five american phd
students are willing willing to
discriminate against right-leaning
scholars according to uh the center for
study of partisanship and ideology you
can go down the list oh there was a
study in uh ezra klein's book why were
polarized where you had people in the
university setting um dole out a
fellowship
and the the single biggest thing that
they would discriminate against someone
for is their political party is that if
someone was the other party then you
would not want to give them good stuff
uh and the majority of the people in
this context were democrats so that
there's definitely something very real
uh and
um you know i don't i don't think it's
good for
learning like if people feel like you
show up and there's like a right opinion
if you don't have the right opinion then
you know like you're going to end up
getting
uh
cast out or attacked by your peers or or
uh the ins the institution itself
uh so yeah like that that is something
that i i think people ought to
be concerned about because like if
everyone's getting trained the same way
that's not what you'd want culturally or
intellectually so it's getting
this is getting spun as like an
anti-woke or intellectual dark web
university and there's a lot of names we
made off some but um here's what i want
to say i just spoke a couple weeks ago
at nyu your man um
for professor talk about um is professor
eli bleich cool guys
former campaign manager he's been in
politics for a while teaching a course
on campaign management so i went and
talked about our race it was fun um
and it brought back a little bit of
nostalgia like being back in a classroom
and that sort of thing and i remember
it reminded me being back in college and
i went to
dukedown north carolina but i remember
going to class and i remember like this
vibe
like mentality like gotta like
buckle my chin strap like wear a helmet
sort of thing where i was ready to
debate in class ready to be told i was
wrong um and that was i was a public
policy major so there was a lot of that
i remember
i grew up in a republican household
moderately republican household and my
first one of my first professors
professor named jessica boone she was
wonderful but she was shaved head
open lesbian like probably as far left
as you could go and we fought all the
time not like or just
she challenged me all day long but in
that class i learned so much
about the left i learned so much about
what it's like growing up a lesbian in
the united states of america i learned
like she and we have a we had a it's one
of the few professors i actually have
communicated with since i've graduated
where in order for people to learn about
other people's views you have to let
them speak their mind and then get
punched um
and when i was in the classroom at nyu
i felt that i
i had this sense and i could see that
students find out there's a feeling but
like you can't say the wrong thing it
was like i felt like i wasn't ready for
battle i was ready to just kind of
massage what we all
are supposedly agreeing to what is right
and i do think that's a massive problem
a massive problem because if you have
young people that aren't willing to
willing to speak and be proven wrong and
then learn
um i don't think that's good learning
and so to barry weiss and the crew i
think this is a good thing um
if it's open dialogue i don't know what
you think if you had that experience in
college too but it hit me hard uh
my favorite thinker in this space is
jonathan height who's been on the
podcast i started something called the
heterodox academy which is one of the
academics in this yeah yeah and and so
i'd surprisingly zero that jonathan's
involved with the university of austin
uh i i think that there is a need for an
environment of just open intellectual
inquiry and you can say something that
other people would consider very
problematic or troublesome
and you're not going to be demonized or
villainized for it you know people may
disagree with you uh but the the big
thing in american life that is going
wrong for us right now is that we are
projecting that someone who disagrees
with us on something is worth less as a
human being than we are at the extreme
we're dehumanizing them we're saying
that you know that they are worth less
actually
uh and that's going to tear us apart
it's going to destroy us so any
environment where people can say what's
on their mind and
not
be
attacked for it i think is a win
uh you know they think that you
shouldn't have this intellectual
conformity or uniformity
because if you do then uh you know
people don't learn as much in my view
and they they become
uh
more timid
or entrenched in their ways like
professor boone like made me
more of a democrat like in that set me
on that path and that um that's how i
met you right um
so i i i owe her a massive favor
so it's like
i you know it's okay to be wrong
as long as you're open-minded to learn
right when you're wrong um no look there
are words you could say that are really
hurtful and you gotta be mindful of that
but
anyway so
university of austin it's you austin.org
um i'm plugging it for because it's
great and you're gonna be on barry's
podcast soon
so did you talk about this at all top
education a bit
uh it hadn't been announced so i don't
think we do okay um
so there's peter bugosians in here barry
weiss uh caitlin flanagan there's a
couple names glenn lowry
uh john mcwhorter i think is involved in
this jonathan height um
so
um worth checking out and they have like
a it's a summer program for now and then
they'll start doing some graduate
programs and then undergraduate
supposedly starts in 2024. i'm a big fan
of new universities starting so amen i
mean like why are we just all lurching
around being like oh universities
they're so expensive oh universities
like you know there aren't enough of
them why don't we just start some new
universities it's so true if you're
listening to this start your own
university i'm kidding it's a lot but um
but you know there's one school uh
dartmouth that said we're going to try
and expand class size by 10 which is a
very very big deal thank goodness
like why are you just keeping your class
size the same when you know that there's
a massive surplus of demand for what you
have to offer you have a mission you
should try and do more of it and the
mission should not be maintain
exclusivity i mean that's jacked up yep
so schools should grow there should be
new schools you'd be doing more and and
yeah like hats off to them for taking on
a difficult challenge because it's not
easy uh you know it's one reason why
again if you're listening to this you
know starting university is probably a
bridge too far but you know but
but feel free to do something that your
community needs you know like start a
new daycare you know you're looking
around and that there's no daycare that
you can be excited about start your own
like that like that should be the
american way the forward way uh and so
i'm i too am excited about the
university of austin plus
like i think austin texas man that that
place seems like like i have friends
who've moved there and friends who live
there and like like that is like the new
frontier zone in a good way uh the
weather is good you know like i did my
brother's bachelor party there
so you know like picked a good hub
picked a catchy name yup um
and look the press
you know
had its way with this announcement and
so did twitter for sure but scott
galloway
has a university as well section four
and it's good it's maybe probably a
little more liberal version of this but
he's a free thinker and um
extremely business savvy so look i'm a
fan of all of this stuff we shouldn't
crucify people trying to build new
things yes build new things there's a
book someone wrote a book called smart
people build things uh or should build
things i don't remember who wrote that
um
i just heard he was a smart guy though
uh
yeah the prototype
oh man all right sb sbt sp
the the one that started at all you
could say
all right
we're out of here man we've been
rambling for a while
good show
yes and i'm going to be
in new york city for a forward book talk
on saturday night the 13th we're going
to make mary drink some wine sign some
books talk about the future join us it's
going to be a blast city winery 7 30 new
york city andrew yang doing stand-up
comedy saturday november 13th you will
laugh you will cry you will drink it's
gonna be great you'll get a selfie maybe
i'll be there you guys are awesome
see you next week
ever forward see you soon
[Music]
you